in the last video we learned that the
pressure at some depth in a fluid is
equal to the density of the fluid times
how deep we are in the fluid or kind of
how highs the column of fluid above us
times gravity let's see if we can use
that to solve a fairly typical problem
you'll see in your physics class or even
on an AP physics test so let's say that
I have a bowl a bowl let me draw the
bowl this is my bowl a bowl and in that
bowl I have mercury and then I also have
this this kind of inverted test tube
that I stick in the middle of this is
the side view of the bowl and I'll draw
everything shortly let's say my test
tube looks something like this so the
test tube that I put in the bowl
something like this and let's say I have
no air in this test tube there's a
vacuum here but the outside of the bowl
this whole area out here this is exposed
to the air and now we are actually on a
on earth we're actually in Paris France
at sea level because that's kind of you
know what what an atmosphere is defined
as so the atmospheric pressure so
essentially the way you could think
about it the weight of all of the air
above us is pushing down on the surface
of this bowl at one atmosphere an
atmosphere is just the pressure of all
of the air above you and at sea level
and in Paris France and in the bowl I
have mercury and mercury is like a
silverish color so I'll draw it as
silver so I have a mercury mercury it's
a flat I know I'm not drawing it
completely flat whoops this is mercury
I want to do it so that I can actually
use the filled tool maybe after just
make sure it has no holes in it I think
I got rid of all the holes okay let me
see let me try to use my fill tool there
you go
and let's say that that mercury there's
no air in here it actually is going to
go up this column a little bit and we're
going to do the math as far as well one
will see why it's going up and then
we'll do the math to figure out how high
up does it go so say the mercury goes up
some distance all right this is all
still mercury it's all still mercury and
it's actually how a barometer works this
is something that measures pressure so
you can imagine up and over here at this
part above the mercury but still within
our our little test tube we have a
vacuum there is no air vacuum one of my
favorite words because it has to use in
a row anyway so anyway what was I doing
oh okay so we have this set up so my
question to you is how high is this
column of mercury going to go how high
is this comma and first well let's just
have the intuition as to why that there
this thing is going up to begin with so
we have all this pressure from all of
the air above us and I know it's a
little unintuitive for us because we
were used to all of that pressure on our
shoulders all of the time so we don't
really imagine it but though there is
literally the weight of the atmosphere
above us and so that's going to be
pushing down on the surface of this of
this of the mercury on the outside of
the test tube and essentially since
there's no pressure here the mercury is
going to go up words here but now is
this the state that I've drawn is a
static state we've assumed that all the
motion is two optics that are etc etc so
let's try to solve this problem oh and a
couple of things we have to we have to
know before we we do this problem it's
mercury and we know that the mercury the
the specific gravity and I'm using
terminology because a lot of these
problems the hardest part is the
terminology the specific gravity
of mercury mercury is 13.6 that's often
a daunting statement on a test when you
know how to do all the math and almost
done you know what is specific gravity
all specific gravity is is the ratio of
how dense that object is that substance
to water so all that means is that
mercury mercury is thirteen point six
times as dense as dense as water right
and hopefully after the last video
because I told you - you should have
memorized the density of water is a
thousand kilograms per meters cubed so
the density of mercury let's write that
down
density that's the row or a little P
depending how you want to view it of
mercury is going to be equal to thirteen
point six times the density of water so
times one thousand kilograms per per
meter cubed okay so let's let's go back
to the problem so what we want to know
is how high this this column of mercury
is so we know that the pressure let's
consider this point right here let's
consider this point right here which is
essentially the base of this column of
mercury what we're saying is the
pressure on the base of this column of
mercury right here the pressure at this
point down pressure down has to be the
same thing as the pressure up right
because the mercury isn't moving we're
in a static state and we learned several
videos ago that the pressure in is equal
to the pressure out of a on a liquid
system so essentially I have one
atmosphere pushing down here on the
outside of the surface I must have one
atmosphere pushing up here so the
pressure pushing up at this point right
here as you could imagine that we have
that aluminum foil there again just
imagine that you know what where the
pressure is hitting the pressure there
is one atmosphere
so the pressure down right here must be
one atmosphere and what's creating the
pressure down right there well it's it's
essentially this column of water or it's
this formula which we learned in the
last video so what we now know is that
the density of the mercury times the
height of the column of water times the
acceleration of gravity on earth which
is where we are has to equal one
atmosphere because it has to offset the
the atmosphere that's pushing on the
outside and pushing up here so let's see
the density of mercury is this thirteen
point six thousand so thirteen thousand
six hundred kilogram meters per meter
cubed
that's the density times the height we
don't know what the height is that's
going to be in meters times the
acceleration of gravity 9.8 meters per
second squared is going to be equal to
one atmosphere and now you're saying Sal
this this is strange I've never seen
this atmosphere before we've talked a
lot about it but how does an atmosphere
relate to Pascal's or Newtons and all of
that so this is something else you
should memorize one atmosphere is equal
to one hundred and three thousand
Pascal's well that also equals one
hundred and three thousand
Newton's per meter squared right
so one atmosphere is how much we're
pushing down out here so it's how much
we're pushing up here and that's going
to be equal to the amount of pressure at
this point from this column of mercury
and one atmosphere is exactly this much
equals one hundred and three thousand
Newton's per meters squared so let's see
let's let's if we divide both sides well
we could just do all of the math so if
we divide both sides by thirteen
thousand six hundred and nine point
eight we get the height is equal to one
hundred and three thousand Newton per
meter cubed
over 13,000 600 kilograms per meter
cubed times 9.8 meter per second squared
and what does that get us do I notice
make sure you always have the unit's
right that's the hardest thing about
these problems just to know that an
atmosphere is a hundred thousand one
hundred and three thousand Pascal's
which is also the same as Newton's per
meter squared now let's just do the math
so let me type this in let me just so
I'll use the pointer 103 thousand
divided by thirteen thousand six hundred
divided by nine point eight equals 0.77
and we're dealing all with Newton's so
height is equal to 0.77 meters and you
should see that the the units actually
work out cuz we have a meters cubed in
the denominator up here we have a meters
cubed in the denominator down here and
then we have kilogram meters per second
squared here and then we have a Newton's
up here but what's a Newton a Newton is
kilogram meter squared per second so
when you divide you know you have
kilogram meter squared per second
squared
here you have kilogram meter per second
squared when you do all the division of
the unit's all you're left with is
meters so we have point seven seven
meters or roughly 77 centimeters is how
high this column of mercury is and you
can make a barometer out of it you can
say oh well we make a little notch on
this test tube and that represents one
atmosphere and you can go around and
figure out what what the atmosphere how
many atmospheres different parts of the
globe are anyway I've run out of time
see in the next video